this is hello goodbye who's leaving
where you going I'm going home where's
home Oh latvia so what brought you here
uh-huh love ya how long have you guys
been together a little over a year and a
half how'd you guys meet yeah we
actually met a lot I was in Dallas and
just yeah saw each other's profile
online and decided to meet up while I
was here yeah my my layover she loved me
the time while she was actually going
school and relationship grew and her
student visas up and they stopped where
to go home so oh the part that we were
both knew that mentioned one day would
come hoping it'd never happen but here
we like so how was it no there's here
it's hard stuff
I mean I was in a marriage probably a
few years ago and getting ready to you
can get to that point to make that
commitment again it's kind of scary you
just wish you had more time to be able
to be what I'm a little bit longer to
you can get to that point you feel like
okay this is right this is it should be
and we do that but time is just
something you don't have tell me what he
means you he's on my mind non stop no
matter what I do he's he's always there
every now and then you need someone in
life that adds to your life that builds
you up and everything about it just
seems like yes yes it's a perfect
partner and in the truth of the matter
is I think you both agree that if we had
time and time wasn't an issue contained
in our relationship with pertained to be
happy together but what do you do are
you fearful that you get on this plane
to be the last time you see
you